attention à la fin de la vidéo j'ai
finalement ça vous faire pour vous
offrir quelques cadeaux donc regarder la
salut pour ce lundi développe je vais
vous emmener avec moi en suisse là je
pars dans quelques minutes
au lido comedy club pour la dernière du
lido comédie à une club de lausanne
la valise est prêt il ya ce soir une
programmation de ouf pour la fermeture
de ce lieu c'est une triste fermeture et
ce lieu culturel va disparaître du coup
tous les artistes qui sont passés là bas
ces dernières années se retrouvent là
bas pour faire un gros plateau de fait
un gros plateau de dernière est
évidemment je vous emmène avec moi c'est
bon je viens d'arriver à lausanne on a
eu un retard de ouf deux heures de
retard dans le train et le public rend
dans la salle dans où il y a plutôt dix
minutes donc je suis très en retard là
j'ai tout mis en vrac ce qui veut dire
que je vais grave le regretter ce soir
puisqu'on va rentré très tard je prends
le train très tôt demain il faudra tout
ranger en fait un coup d'oeil aux mages
c'est nous qu'on sur l'éducation
si vous voulez voir des verts dans mon
spectacle enfin pendant tout le temps
qu'il faut me demander à moi
c'est le régisseur allons y ressemble
grâce à ces deux médias
au vu de ma carrière j'ai fait un choix
plutôt judicieux
je suis orienté vers la régie et les
pizzas en fait j'aime pas mais c'est
vraiment g60 est très important qu'il a
envie toujours le même moment la pizza
sans fin on est sur une grande tristesse
au niveau de la répartition du poulet ça
fait tellement mal au coeur rester mais
au fait qu'est-ce qui t'a végétalienne
en fait je dis tout match de sa tunisie
vainqueur en grands sièges coûté la
seule petite dedans bonjour euh youtube
je connais ce qu'ils ont subi bonjour
youtube bonjour youtube c'est blanc n'a
bizarrement pas vous mais je suis
devenue célèbre moteur des conneries
comme ça en même temps fois bravo c'est
un schéma rimbaud et sa famille et ça
c'est tout l'intérêt de mettre une robe
le real madrid assurant que tu aimais
limite seulement jardin
merci j'avais été déçu
marine allemande est debout dans la
salle ça veut dire qu'il ya trop de
monde et qui réceptionne me souviens le
cross et qui envahissent
c'est pas bien gardé
et tout le monde ce soir mais sur
l'éclat avec vous ma vie je vais vous
montrer
car rien également
l'année
personne
je sais pas
joyau français cabral modèle
il a révisé à l'aller le père si aussi
là sur l efficacité
comment cet hôpital
la française françois
m
et
il est
oui
ils en ont
o o
mais
indiqué moussa
imagine
oh
merci
j'espère que ce petit blog sur la suisse
vous a plu on n'a pas pu avoir beaucoup
d'image c'était compliqué on était
trente artistes juste après les autres
au jeu vous fait l'annoncé sur les
choses que je voulais vous offrir et si
ce blog vous a plu n'hésitez pas à me le
faire savoir en laissant par exemple
peut-être un petit pouce en l'air
n'oubliez pas également de vous abonner
avant de partir puisque le mental blog
c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
depuis ce 1er janvier jusqu'au 31
décembre donc rendez vous demain à 17h
ciao
si vous me suivez sur les réseaux
sociaux sur snap instagram facebook ou
twitter vous avez vu qu'il ya quelques
jours le site du goéland point fr m'a
envoyé quelques nouveaux t-shirts pour
les vidéos et ça c'est plutôt sympa de
leur part c'est parce qu'ils ont vu que
je portais leur t-shirt dans ma vidéo et
avec les t-shirts ils m'ont envoyé plein
d'auto collants genre ça ça ou encore ça
alors j'en ai gardé un de chaque
exemplaire pour moi et je me suis dit
que j'allais simplement vous offrir les
autres donc je fais un concours simple
vous m'envoyer un mail à l'adresse qui
va s'afficher ici que je mets dans le
descriptif c'est une adresse mail que
pour le concours donc m'écrivent et pas
pour autre chose dessus vous m'en voyez
donc un mail à cette adresse avec votre
nom prénom votre adresse et votre âge et
en fin de semaine grâce à un des sites
que vous m'avez conseiller je ferai un
tirage au sort de cinq personnes à qui
j'en verrai 3 autocollant est également
le jeu que j'offre dans mon spectacle
qui est un jeu qui permet de mentaliser
legends 3 fois voilà j'espère que ça
vous fera plaisir parce que moi ça me
fait plaisir de vous offrir ça à bientôt
ciao